A BIDEN SWEEP YET AGAIN, WE WILL
WATCH THE NEXT ONE AND SEE WHEN
FOLKS EVENTUALLY GET TO THE
POLLS, THANKS.
THE GOVERNMENT MAINTAINS CONTROL
OVER INDIVIDUALS TO SERVE THE
GREATER GOOD BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
DANGER TO CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
FINDING A BALANCE?
THAT DEBATE IS PLAYING OUT IN
NEW YORK FOR THE CITIES MAYOR IS
THINKING ABOUT LOCKING THE
ENTIRE CITY DOWN BUT SO FAR THE
GOVERNOR SAYS NOT ON HIS WATCH.
>> NO CITY CAN QUARANTINE ITSELF
WITHOUT STATE APPROVAL.
I HAVE NO INTEREST WHATSOEVER
AND NO PLAN WHATSOEVER TO
QUARANTINE ANY CITY.
>> Shannon: DELICATE BALANCING
ACT WITH FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL JOHN YOO AND
SEATTLE RADIO TALK SHOW HOST
JASON RAINES.
I WAS LOOKING AROUND TODAY FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT QUARANTINES
FROM THE PAST AND I STUMBLED
UPON THIS DOCUMENT FROM THE ACLU
THAT THEY PUT TOGETHER IN 2008
CALLED "PANDEMIC PREPAREDNESS."
TOO OFTEN, FEARS AROUND
EPIDEMICS HAVE TESTIFIED ABUSES
OF STATE POWER, HIGHLY
DISCRIMINATORY AND ENFORCEABLE
VACCINE AND QUARANTINE MEASURES
IN RESPONSE TO THE PLAGUE AND
SMALLPOX HAVE CONSISTENTLY
ACCELERATED RATHER THAN SLOWED
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE WHILE
FOMENTING PUBLIC DISTRUST AND
THEN SOME CASES RIOTS.
IT’S QUITE A MOUTHFUL.
>> WE CAN LOOK AT HISTORY AND
LEARN FROM ENTS IN THE PAST
BUT THOSE ARE TIMES WHEN PEOPLE
DIDN’T KNOW ABOUT GERM THEORY.
I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
NOW IS A MUCH BETTER WAY TO
LEARN WHICH IS TO LOOK AT WHAT
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE DONE, FOR
EXAMPLE DR. OZ A WHILE AGO SAID
SOUTH KOREA HAS DONE A GOOD JOB,
CHINA HAS NOW TURNED THE CORNER
ON IT, WE CAN ALSO LEARN FROM
PLACES LIKE ITALY WHERE POLICIES
SEEM TO HAVE FAILED.
WE DON’T HAVE TO LOOK BACK A
HUNDRED YEARS OR 50 YEARS AT
PANICS, WE CAN LOOK AT THE
EVIDENCE BEFORE US.
I THINK THERE ARE CERTAIN
POLICIES WHICH SEEM TO BE
WORKING BUT WE CAN GO TOO FAR.
I’M LIVING IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
THE BERKELEY AREA WHERE WE SEEM
TO BE UNDER A TOTAL LOCKDOWN OF
ALMOST ALL SOCIAL ACTIVITY, THAT
MIGHT BE GOING TOO FAR BUT I
DON’T THINK IT’S A VIOLATION OF
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, I THINK
IT’S WE ARE TRYING TO REACH THE
RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN STOPPING
THE SPREAD OF THE DISEASE AND
NOT TOTALLY PUTTING THE ECONOMY
INTO A SEIZURE SO THAT PEOPLE
WHO NEED MONEY WHO NEED TO WORK
ON TABLE TWO.
>> Shannon:
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAD THIS
HEADLINE, THE GOVERNMENT CAN
QUARANTINE YOU FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS AND THERE’S NOTHING
YOU COULD DO ABOUT IT --
REGULATIONS ENFORCED BY THE CDC
GIVE HEALTH OFFICIALS BROAD
AUTHORITY TO QUARANTINE OR
ISOLATE ANY ONE "REASONABLY
BELIEVED TO HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
A RANGE OF HIGHLY INFECTIVE
DISEASES.
"YOU ARE OUT THERE ON THE
WEST COAST WHERE YOU HAVE A BIG
EXPLOSION OF THIS AND THERE ARE
SOME MEASURES IN PLACE, HOW IS
IT PLAYING OUT THERE?
>> IT’S PLAYING OUT IN THE WAY
YOU WOULD EXPECT IT TO, LOTS OF
PEOPLE ARE NERVOUS, LOTS OF
PEOPLE ON THE BRINK OF PANIC.
WE HEARD EARLIER TODAY THAT THE
SCHOOLS MAY STAY CLOSED INTO THE
FALL.
WE ARE CONSTANTLY HEARING RUMORS
ABOUT A SAN FRANCISCO STYLE
POLICY THAT WILL KEEP PEOPLE
INDOORS.
YOU WALK AROUND, DRIVE AROUND
THE CITY OF SEATTLE, IT’S
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
THERE AREN’T MANY PEOPLE ON THE
ROADS, CERTAINLY NOT MANY PEOPLE
IN BUSINESSES AND A LOT OF THEM
HAVE HAD TO SHUT DOWN.
THERE’S A FEAR THAT THEY AREN’T
GOING TO OPEN UP AGAIN.
NOT ONLY ARE WE DEALING WITH THE
HEALTH CONCERNS AND THE PANIC
ABOUT A POTENTIALLY DEADLY VIRUS
DEPENDING ON THE DEMOGRAPHIC
THAT GETS IT, YOU ARE ALSO
WORRIED ABOUT PAYING RENT,
PAYING COMMON BILLS, GOING ABOUT
YOUR NORMAL LIFE AND I THINK AT
SOME POINT THEY ARE GOING TO
INTERSECT IN A WAY THAT NEEDS TO
BE MANAGED.
I’M WONDERING IF WE ARE PREPARED
FOR THAT.
>> Shannon: WE ARE GOING TO
PLAY SOMETHING BY THE SURGEON
GENERAL TODAY, HERE IS HIS TAKE
ON THIS.
>> WE ARE NOT AN AUTHORITARIAN
NATION, WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
WHEN WE SAY "LET’S DO IT CHINA
DID, LET’S DO IT SOUTH KOREA
DID."
A LOT OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITY RELIES IN THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL.
>> Shannon: I’VE BEEN HEARING
THIS DEBATE BACK AND FORTH.
THE STATES ARE DOING EVERYTHING
BECAUSE THE FEDS AREN’T MANAGING
IT WELL AND ON THE OTHER HANDS
THEY ARE SAYING YOU’VE GOT TO
WATCH THIS TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
THEY HAVE THESE AUTHORITARIAN
TENDENCIES AND YOU CAN’T LET
THEM START CRACKING THINGS DOWN
ON HIGH FROM THE FED.
WHERE DO PEOPLE FIND THAT
BALANCE?
>> IT’S IRONIC THAT PEOPLE ARE
ATTACKING TRUMP NOW FOR NOT
BEING ACTIVIST ENOUGH WHEN TWO
MONTHS AGO, PEOPLE WERE
ATTACKING TRUMP, TRYING TO
REMOVE HIM FROM OFFICE BECAUSE
THEY WERE WORRIED HE WAS
EXERCISING TO WATCH PRESIDENTIAL
POWER.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
DO AND WITH THE STATE GOVERNMENT
CAN DO, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CAN CONTROL THE BORDERS, IT CAN
PROVIDE A LOT OF MONEY, IT CAN
PROVIDE A LOT OF SUPPLIES, THE
REAL POWER OF GOVERNMENT TO
HANDLE AN EPIDEMIC LIKE THIS
THAT’S NOT LOCALIZED IN ONE
PLACE, THAT THE SPREADING OUT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY IS IN THE
STATE GOVERNMENTS.
THAT’S THE WAY OUR CONSTITUTION
IS DESIGNED AND FEDERAL LAW
STILL GIVES THE FRONT LINE
RESPONSIBILITY TO GOVERNORS,
MAYORS, COUNTY EXECUTIVES
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES WHO
CONTROL THE RESOURCES AND THE
PERSONNEL THAT CAN REALLY
ENFORCE THINGS LIKE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN’T
HAVE THE PEOPLE OR THE RESOURCES
TO DO ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
IN A WEIRD WAY, IT’S A SUCCESS
FOR THE PRESIDENT IN DEALING
WITH THIS EPIDEMIC, IT’S GOING
TO LIE IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE
LIKE GAVIN NEWSOM OR
ANDREW CUOMO.
>> Shannon: THEY BOTH HAVE HAD
PRAISE FOR HIM IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS AND THEY ARE ARCHENEMIES
OTHERWISE.
SPEAKING OF GOVERNORS,
GOVERNOR NORTHAM TWEETS I JUST
ISSUED AN EMERGENCY ORDER TO
ENFORCE VIRGINIA’S STATEWIDE BAN
OF MORE THAN TEN PATRONS AND
RESTAURANTS, THEATERS, AND
FITNESS CENTERS.
PLEASE USE COMMON SENSE IF YOU
ARE CONSIDERING IGNORING THIS
LIMIT, DON’T.
AT WHAT POINT DO YOU HAVE ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT AUTHORITIES USING
WHATEVER RESOURCES THEY HAVE.
TO CRACK DOWN ON PEOPLE WHO
DON’T GO ALONG WITH WHAT IS FOR
NOW A VOLUNTARY AT LEAST WHERE
WHERE WE ARE IN VIRGINIA, A
VOLUNTARY SUGGESTION.
>> HERE’S WHERE I’M CONCERNED.
I’M CONCERNED WHEN PEOPLE DECIDE
THEY DON’T THINK THIS IS SERIOUS
ENOUGH TO DO THE SELF ISOLATION.
I FEAR SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
PUT GOVERNORS OR MAYORS IN
POSITION WHERE THEIR HANDS ARE
TIED AND THEY ARE GOING TO START
MOVING DOWN THE LINE OF THESE
KINDS OF MASSIVE QUARANTINES.
I’VE BEEN TALKING TO PEOPLE ON
BOTH SIDES.
ON THE LEFT, I NEED TO HEAR
PEOPLE STOPPING THIS NONSENSE,
POLITICKING AND GOING AFTER
TRUMP WHATEVER THEY CAN AND
TAKING IT OUT OF CONTEXT BECAUSE
THEY ARE DOWNPLAYING THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS.
ON THE RIGHT, I SAY THE SAME
THING AND I’M A CONSERVATIVE BUT
I’M TALKING TO FOLKS ON MY SIDE
TO SAYING LET’S CHILL OUT A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT ANY KIND OF
CRITICISM AGAINST THE PRESIDENT,
THERE ARE GOOD FAITH CRITICISMS
THAT WE CAN LEVEL AND STOP WITH
THE CONSPIRACY THAT ALL OF A
SUDDEN THE POLICE ARE GOING TO
TAKE OVER AND WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE PEOPLE WITH GUNS WANDERING
AROUND THE STREETS KEEPING US IN
OUR HOMES, WE AREN’T TO THAT
POINT.
BUT IF WE DON’T TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY AND DON’T FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIVES COMING FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS COMING FROM
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND COMING
FROM OUR GOVERNORS, I THINK WE
ARE GOING TO FORCE THEIR HAND.
I KNOW FOLKS LIKE JOHN ARE OUT
THERE WHO ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF THERE ARE ANY LEGITIMATE
CIVIL LIBERTIES DISRUPTIONS,
THEY’RE GOING TO CALL THIS OUT.
RIGHT NOW I’M MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE GUY YOU PLAYED EARLIER
GOING OUT ON THE BEACH AND